Film Courage: I was watching this documentary
last night and it had me thinking about maybe
your situation and that is these filmmakers
[in the documentary] had been accepted into
this prestigious program and they thought
they’d just try applying to the school.
When they got the acceptance letter it felt
as if someone was almost playing a joke on
them.
Justin Warren, Filmmaker: Absolutely.
Film Courage: Then [beforehand] we were talking
off-camera that sparked this question.
So was this something that something you went
through when applying to leave was it Hendrix
College?
Justin Warren: Yeah, so basically I applied
to film school kind of as a built-in excuse
to not pursue my dreams (if that makes sense).
So I was just like I’m going to apply to
USC [University of Southern California] film
school and no one gets into there.
I’m going to apply, get rejected and then
I can say I tried and go about my life.
I was going to work at like a gas company
in Arkansas.
That was what I was going to do after graduation.
And I ended up actually not doing that and
I worked as a youth director for a little
while.
I applied to USC in the middle of planning
my wedding basically.
Film Courage: Oh…wow.
Justin Warren: I got a response one day, literally
an email that said…the subject line was
“RSVP For Admitted Student’s Day,” because
I guess they sent the email in the wrong order.
And I was like “Admitted student’s day?
What does that mean?”
And then a few minutes later I got an admissions
decision thing so I found out kind of in reverse
and I was so confused.
I did…I thought someone played a joke on
me.
I found out I got into USC about two weeks
before I was going to get married.
I was so stunned and I was talking to my wife
and was like “So I’m not going to go.”
And she’s like “No, no, no…you have
to go.”
My wife was in the middle of pharmacy school
at the time.
She couldn’t just pick up and leave what
she was doing.
So that meant she pushed me to say yes and
to purse my dreams.
So we got married and then literarily two
weeks later after we got married I moved to
Los Angeles to start film school.
It was pretty wild.
It was amazing because (and it’s a testament
to how amazing my wife is), if she hadn’t
pushed me to say “Yes go pursue your dreams,”
I probably wouldn’t have done it, I probably
wouldn’t have.
Film Courage: And how long until she joined
you here [in California]?
Justin Warren: We were apart for two years.
For the first two years of film school I was
just out here by myself in a long-distance
marriage which was pretty wild, but it worked
out great.
Film Courage: Wow…I think that would be
tough for a lot of people to be separated
for a long time like this…and plus had you
been to Los Angeles before?
Justin Warren: No, no…I’d never been to
California at all.
So it was almost like a fish-out-of-water
experience.
I got here and I remember one of the first
things was just showing up at LAX [Los Angeles
International Airport] is scary.
Film Courage: It’s scary!
Justin Warren: It’s terrifying.
You are like “Wait?
Whoah!
This one terminal is the size of my entire
airport where I am from.”
And cars circle [around the airport] and keep
circling.
Film Courage: Yes!
It’s called ‘panic attack circle.’
Justin Warren: Exactly and I stepped out of
the airport and suddenly felt like I was on
a completely new planet.
And then what was weird was I remember when
I got to school, the crosswalks counted down
from 30.
And back where I am at home, they count down
from 10 and I was like “What is this?
It’s going to take me 30 second to get across
the street?”
And in a lot of places it does.
So it was very strange and I remember the
first time I parked my car in the parking
deck at USC, I didn’t have that skill where
you are like “Okay, let me remember what
row I’m on.”
And I just parked my car and went to class
and when I came back, I couldn’t find my
car and me and my friend spent like four hours
in the parking deck looking for my car (this
is an eight-story parking).
Film Courage: I’ve been there.
Justin Warren: I had now idea where my car
was.
That was one of my first experiences out here.
Film Courage: And people drive pretty fast,
too (in that parking garage).
Justin Warren: Yeah, absolutely.
Film Courage: Well, the second part of that
question goes to the fact that these same
people [in the documentary film we’re referring
to] who were accepted and thought someone
was playing a joke on them, they got in.
Then they were in this setting where they
were getting peer feedback and had never been
through a process like this before.
It was actually quite upsetting them.
Justin Warren: Totally.
Film Courage: And it kind of broke people
(at least some of them).
Justin Warren: Absolutely.
Film Courage: I was just wondering (maybe
you can talk in general terms) how that was
to get feedback?
Justin Warren: Yeah, it’s a weird experience.
And I say this all with love and stuff for
USC because it’s my alma mater and I love
it with all my heart.
But the feedback process (especially in film
school) is like unnerving in so many ways
because it’s almost like tearing down people’s
work is almost like sport.
It’s like “Yeah, you think you’re good?
Well, check this out.”
And at the end of the day it’s all out of
love even thought it’s really hard, harsh
love.
It’s all about making work better.
But coming from me, I’d never really experienced
that before.
I remember the first time we played my dailies,
there was a room of like 50 people in it.
And I’ll never forget this…this one…the
first comment that I got, somebody raised
their hand and said “It doesn’t look this
movie was directed my anybody?”
And I was like ohhhh….[cries out in pain]….yeah…that’s
what I’m in for.
And the funny part was they were kind of right
because you just couldn’t tell any intention
in my work at the time, you know?
But that was the tone of how rough the notes
process moving forward throughout school.
What’s weird is after that class I actually
went and cried in the courtyard.
I went and I was like “I’ll be right back,
guys.”
And I went and I wept and I wept bitterly.
I had a moment after I wept and I realize
“Oh, I’m still here…I’m still here.
I can try again.”
And it seems like that process sort of…it
sharpened me if you will.
And now I absolutely love people’s feedback
on my work.
I love it and now (I’ve had this with my
first feature) I’ve had people literally
walk up to me and say “This is the worst
movie I’ve ever seen.”
I’m like “Okay.
That’s fine.”
And it doesn’t really bother me anymore
because I know my work ethic.
I know my intentions as the director.
I know what I am trying to do.
So it helped me in the long run.
And now actually I love it because I think
the notes process, the feedback process only
sharpens your work and makes it better if
you know what your intention behind the work
is.
So I love it.